2022 looks to hopefully be the year of
kratos with 2018's playstation classic
god of war releasing on pc on january
14th and its sequel god of war ragnarok
still scheduled for later this year
we're all about to get a lot of the god
of big dad energy i made a deal with the
god that cost me my soul
so we figured this was the best time to
look back at 13 of the coolest secrets
easter eggs and facts about the god of
war franchise that you probably didn't
know even if you're the goddess of
wisdom athena there's sure to be at
least one fact on this list that you
didn't know before but before we get
started if you like this type of content
don't forget to give us a like and
subscribe it really helps us out but
with that said let's jump into the
bifrost
2005's original god of war was a huge
game changer for the industry and it was
actually initially inspired by god of
war's game designer david jaffe having
played the japanese game animusha a game
about a ninja going through japanese
myths to kill demons jaffe felt inspired
to make a game like animusha except
using greek mythology instead of
japanese he also drew upon aiko to
inspire the game's puzzles devil may cry
for the action and even american mcgee's
alice for how to take familiar
characters and put a twist on them all
of these eventually got mixed together
to create the beautiful gore-filled
classic that is god of war
the gods of olympus have abandoned me
one of the biggest changes the 2018 game
made to the franchise was giving kratos
a son named atreus forcing the god of
war to have to think slightly less about
killing everything in sight and more
about how to raise a child in a brutal
world boy
look at me
we did it
yet as radical as this change was kratos
having a child was actually part of some
of the earliest iterations of the
character back during the initial stages
of development for the 2005 ps2 game
many designs for kratos were considered
some featured him with long hair or
dreadlocks instead of his bald head and
tattooed look however one of the most
notable images included him carrying a
baby on his back a la death stranding
this would have certainly made for an
interesting change to the initial game's
trend setting gameplay and one wonders
if it would have come coupled with
kratos downing a ton of monster energy
drinks in order to kill more medusas so
thankfully it didn't make it into the
game however it was an interesting if
unintentional foreshadowing for the
ghost of sparta's later adventures
speaking of the god of war's origins
while kratos does seem right at home in
the pantheon of greek gods he is an
original character made for the games
however that doesn't mean that he was
entirely made up out of whole cloth
in fact kratos actually is inspired by
the greek god kratos also known as the
god of strength might power and
sovereign rule kratus often advocates
for unnecessary violence and is known to
be merciless so
you can probably see where the two share
a ton of similarities
however there are a few key differences
such as kratos being a full god versus
kratos's demigod status kratos is also
perhaps best known for convincing the
god hephaestus to chain prometheus to a
rock as punishment for his theft of fire
where his liver would be eaten by birds
again and again for all time conversely
kratos in the games actually is the one
to free prometheus eventually letting
him die and using his ashes to free
pegasus
so
maybe kratos has a bit more mercy than
his mythological counterpart
[Music]
but only only a bit more
the first god of war game was trend
setting for its let's say liberal use of
violence or nudity causing a bit of a
minor controversy upon its release
especially around its sex minigame
yet it wasn't the sex that got the game
ultimately censored while god of war
would be released mostly untouched in
the united states there was one scene
that was deemed too much for a european
and japanese audiences at one point in
the game in order to progress kratos is
required to give a human sacrifice in
the us version kratos finds a greek
soldier trapped in a cage who is filled
with hope that kratos will release him
from starving to death let me out we can
find our way back to athens
the gods demand sacrifice
from all of us
oh please no
no kratos instead pushes the soldier up
a hill as the soldier screams for
release let me out please show mercy
finally kicking him into flames where he
is burnt alive allowing kratos to move
forward
obviously not exactly an easy to watch
scene in fact the scene was so brutal
that in european and japanese versions
the soldier is replaced with an angry
undead enemy gutting the scene of its
impact on both kratos character and the
player at least hopefully the soldier
got to see his family again in that
version we hope maybe kinda
have you ever wished you could just call
up kratos on your phone for a nice chat
your son has returned i bring the
destruction of olympus well surprise you
actually can give your favorite greek
demigod a ring to this day at the end of
the original god of war there's two
statues hanging in your new god chambers
of the bosses that you beat throughout
the game however you're kratos and you
don't need statues to remind you of your
conquests so if you spend a good chunk
of time just hacking away at the statues
they'll eventually collapse revealing a
code that you can put together into a
phone number and if you call that number
the god of war himself would answer and
even be interrupted by david jaffe
though things don't really end well for
the god of war creator in the call
together we shall conquer the perils
that lay before us and we shall all
do dude they did it they found our
easter egg
who are you it's me david jaffe i
directed the game
what game the number which is on screen
right now still works to this day
believe me i tested it so if you feel
like giving your favorite greek god a
call check it out speaking of cell
phones while everyone knows the mainline
games god of war god of war 2 god of war
3 2018's god of war as well as the
spin-off games including god of our
ascension goes to sparta and chains of
olympus there is one game that most
people often completely forget when
discussing the franchise god of war
betrayal betrayal was a 2007 game made
exclusively for mobile phones back when
we all thought playing games on your
flip phone was a good idea the game was
a 2d side-scroller that acted as a
sequel to the first game with kratos
newly christened as the god of war being
framed for the murder of argos and
pursuing the true killer throughout the
game to clear his name in fact the story
of the game is used as justification for
why the relationship between kratos and
the rest of the gods changed between god
of war 1 and 2 leading to their betrayal
surprisingly the game actually received
positive reviews with it being praised
for its tight gameplay and fun combat so
if you're a franchise completionist you
may want to dig out your flip phone and
give it a try
okay this fact is a little bit of a duh
but it's kind of too funny not to
mention the initial god of war was
incredibly influential and it led to a
ton of clones of the game for years to
come some like dante's inferno or
castlevania lord of shadows were
actually well received however there
were some less than stellar and
sometimes bizarre knockoffs for example
the mcu tie-in game thor god of thunder
may initially make sense to steal god of
war's signature style given that you're
also playing as a mythological god but
its bland gameplay couldn't match up to
the dazzling brutality of kratos however
the strangest knockoff had to be sonic
unleashed where half the game had you
playing as a beast mode version of our
favorite hedgehog who played exactly
like kratos look i get that sometimes
you want to chase a trend but whoever
thought having sonic the fastest thing
alive suffer through these plotting pace
destroying levels sadly didn't
understand what made both sonic or god
of war great which is sad considering
the actual sonic-like levels of
unleashed are actually a ton of fun but
are sadly lost in between these boring
rip-off levels
jumping forward a bit 2010's god of war
3 was initially billed as kratos's final
adventure while we all know today that
that's not true even the game at the
time decided to leave things open for
future games at the end of god of war 3
kratos opens pandora's box releasing the
evil inside to corrupt the gods but also
imbuing kratos with hope when athena
demands he return this power of hope to
her kratos instead stabs himself
seemingly killing himself to give hope
to all of mankind however a post-credit
scene reveals a trail of blood off the
mountain hinting at kratos survival we
wouldn't see what happened next to the
god of war until he reappeared in 2018's
soft reboot however the novelization of
the game offers a few interesting
tidbits of what happened in those
missing years first it was revealed that
kratos again tried to kill himself after
god of war 3 but was unable to due to a
curse by the greek gods preventing him
from ending his life further he also
tried to discard the blades of chaos and
while he was able to remove them from
his body he ultimately couldn't truly
leave them behind completely again
cursed to have them close to him for the
rest of his life additionally kratos was
brought to midgard by a mysterious woman
and three wolves eventually revealed to
be fenrir skull and haiti from there he
met his future wife and they built the
house that you start the game in where
they lived for at least 50 years until
the start of the game meeting no one
else as they raised their son atreus
[Music]
okay this is a fun one because it
involves a mistake from us right here at
gamespot right after god of war was
revealed at e3 2016 a god of war article
about the game referred to atreus as
charlie for some reason look e3 is
pretty hectic alright why a young kid in
a god of war game would be named charlie
is beyond us but it certainly would have
made for an interesting choice for the
character in fact the creators of god of
war found it so funny that they actually
named freya's giant tortoise surely
after our mistake so in the end we got
to name a giant tortoise and i think
that makes it all worth it in the end is
he friendly
boy
speaking of god of war 2018 one of the
other biggest changes it made was to the
actor playing kratos get in the boat boy
for most of the other mainline games
actor tc carson had voice kratos however
in an interview with youtube channel
djvlad carson revealed that until 2018
he had only provided the voice over for
the character with another actor doing
the mocap work
my vengeance
ends now
for the reboot sony wanted an actor who
could do both at the same time and so
actor christopher judge best known for
his work as tealk on stargate sg1 was
cast
indeed
while carson holds no ill will to sony
or the developers he did state that he
felt a bit disrespected for never
getting a call telling him that he no
longer had the job
speaking of actors though god of war
sequel ragnarok was originally set to
come out in 2021 but was delayed until
2022 while most people assumed this was
due to problems caused by the ongoing
global pandemic christopher judge in
september 2021 came out to say that the
other reason was due to an injury he
sustained in 2019 i need to be
forthcoming this has been approved by no
one to the beloved fandom ragnarok was
delayed because of me had to have back
surgery both hips replaced and knee
surgery they waited for me to rehab in
the end we're all just glad that judge
is doing well and that he got to
continue playing the character and that
the developers have even more time to
sharpen their game to perfection
this next piece of info comes from our
own interview with god of war's director
corey barlog for our series audio logs
in the discussion it was revealed that
during the scene where kratos floats
down the river to retrieve his blades of
chaos for he initially wanted there to
be hell walkers all around the ridge
around kratos battling each other
showing chaos all around the demigod as
he had his moment of silence in his boat
however due to budget constraints all
that had to be cut leaving the scene to
be a bit more empty which cory actually
thinks was for the best because it
allowed you to better feel kratos
isolation
for our final tidbit like kratos let's
dive into one of the darkest pits of
humanity
twitter on the first day of 2020 corey
barlog tweeted first tweet of the new
decade eric williams remember that name
heart emoji the enigmatic tweet sent
many into a huge amount of speculation
was eric williams some strangely named
new enemy and god of war was the prime
minister of trinidad named eric williams
somehow involved with the game or how
about one of the most notorious texas
killers also named eric williams
okay turns out none of those were true
but instead eric williams turned out to
be the name of the man who would become
god of war ragnarok's game director well
not as immediately exciting as his
political or notorious namesakes we're
sure eric williams will be a fine leader
for the upcoming end of the norse world
while corey oversees as creative
director at sony santa monica studio
and that's our list for 13 cool things
you may not have known about god of war
we hope that it brought you some wisdom
as you jump back into the series on
either pc or are waiting patiently with
us for ragnarok to finally fall later
this year and if you want more
interesting info right for the man who
helped craft the game check out our
aforementioned audio log with corey
barlog until then don't forget to like
and subscribe and we'll see you all in
midgard